déjà la ministre elle avait quitté y
aller avec moi me titiller les choix
avec madoff oui elle ras sera maman ou à
lille avec lui connaît ou pas les races
raté jour ton mec qui va te faire une
surprise et amène deux billets pour
venise tu côtoies apprend les billets
ahmed mois à limoges la petite côte le
mail moi je t'aime à porcelaine sans
rigoler c'est quoi vous connaissez les
surprises ripoux pour que tout le monde
a fait genre tu vas gagner moi je suis
jamais la venise etc une meuf et moi qui
fait jamais pouvoir des plus jeunes je
préfère rester à paris
sur l'année mais que sa vie pour des
pigeons qui ce qu'on va voir à venise
des gondoles frère de noix zodiac levé
sur la scène
on va vivre à l'année à venir et
romantique à plus de romantisme à mon
mari voulait bien nommé pour le voyage
de noces j'ai préféré ainsi mais vous
avez raison bravo tout cas vous avez
toujours une vie magnifique
et incroyable
projet à venelles et celle record
à mordelles et petit bateau comme ça et
tout s'est dégonflé
des petits bateaux rivard possible à
l'inde mais c'est magnifique les
breuvages tarit pas je tenais pas
acheter c'est très bien c'est quoi ces
chercheurs oui tu en avais un toit
rivard et n'ont jamais non jamais non
jamais rien fait
alors vous êtes qui a été à venise avec
fatou quatre jours avec facois vous oui
fatou mushkin
le piranha c'est que vous voyez tous les
autres amoureux et vous vous dites
rencontre photo lc 10 r
parce que vous avez tous les amoureux du
monde entier ça veut dire tu vois ce
moment là où tu en es dans ta vie c'est
revenir fatouma finale est avec gilles
verdez à la noble sans rigoler elle a vu
jennifer botbol de 2,2 dans le sentirais
sale était avec 15 minutes et dcti
mechiche sportifs chez decathlon
éclata et elles étaient accueillies en
train de manger des spaghettis comme ça
sur le port laurine un menu aux plantes
qu'on nous avait fait spécialement mais
il y avait ramassé ses plans pc les
goûts mais aussi de faire ces délicieux
surnom bien foutus de notre gueule
mais combien football
mais perdez vous et gardez vous devenez
plus perdez vous tous et vous tous
organise ne revenait plus vous avez été
au bon je suis allé à venise mais
c'était pour qui mens de la ligne
amenant s'était fiancé toujours prendre
de l'oseille
[Rires]
c'est fait
au jour pour le lancement c'est pour le
lancement d'avions pillent tuent ces
images on place voilà non mais c'était
gratos c'est l'ouverture de la ligne
c'était l'ouverture de la ligne air
france bordeaux ils ont trouvé que toi
que j'étais là mais la vingtaine ah
ouais génial 20 pique-assiette
l'arrière pays en a fait les meilleurs
restos les meilleurs auteurs à faire un
peu l'histoire dans la vie enfin c'est
l'histoire de ma vie oui il est en vie
ou qui a été petit toit deux fois et
jeunes ont séparé deux fois après mais
tu as raison que nous sommes toi tu leur
en faire sa renommée et chaque épisode
suit encore une fois d'accord avec mr
oui on est comme ça fouet qui l'habite
de leçon pour comprendre mais pas du
temps il n'a pas été capable matt
exactement mairie mais toi c'est arrivé
c'est alors oui c'est un récidiviste
monsieur madame x qui tire à sa fin
venir ce qui s'est passé pendant
les deux jours suivants je me suis
séparé c'était une race re ah ouais
horrible je connais et ponies alors à
venise attention je vous le dis et vous
connaissez pas ces pnj majine
il ya beaucoup de choses que je connais
pas mais j'en parle encore mieux quand
je ne connais pas
si vous voulez vous qui est une grande
personne au chômage
[Musique]
soit 3,4 à un taux n'est toi là-bas
attendait les bacs croire en son étoile
voilà
merci
merci je rappelle que c'est lionel tim
qui faisait partie des les lie avec matt
pokora et otis qu'on embrasse
et vous qu'on embrasse péter la matte
boccara qu'on embrasse également macbook
en l'embrassant
[Rires]
il ya un cluster de recaler je te jure
il ya un coaster sur la lys est vrai que
ce ne serait pas alors je vous le dis
venir en fait très attention venise il
faut y aller quand on est sûr de soi
parce que sinon et j'ai eu plusieurs
copains du monde où ils te montrent une
faute dalaba non je vous jure mais tu te
retrouves avec ta meuf au bout du
deuxième jour à venise avec des gens
place avec ces clubs là
à faire des coeurs qui t'as pas un tel
pack pour aller manger des spaghettis tu
sais même pas d'où ils viennent au frère
je te le dire s'ils n'étaient pas
solides dans ton couple tu vas venir tu
es mort est mort va plutôt à melun
gros pas de risque était tranquille ce
bon coup je te jure daniel spectateurs
nantes a pas de quoi les fac d'éco nice
ans tu sois toi ça fusionnent et ce à
quoi ça ça c'est partout jury la raison
attention hein alors je le dis parce que
là on est le con bien là on est le cas
des
produits
décembre 8 décembre jour se voir ma paye
le dans 22 jours
oui oui d'ailleurs d'ailleurs pour mais
amener de l'eau à son moulin mais la
rétention c'est que c'est triste
exactement passé reste une séparation
c'est ça il a raison la mort en droit
charles aznavour il était plus
intelligents que nous sinon ça serait
partial aznavour serait rené la taupe
bien sûr et charlene ont hélas diamant
nous parce que je voulais vous dire mais
c'est vous très très important les 20
prochains jours sont
vraiment décisif dans l'histoire des
couples c'est là que ça va jouir je vous
le dis attention ne prenez pas de
décision hâtive du genre une meuf
convient de connaître bien passer noël
chez les parents parlent à guillaume
alors je connais ça je connais ça tu vas
chez les parents tu as toujours ton
d'aaron hill et cammas il a un morceau
de guez mer ici
je connais ça m'est arrivé très réglos
bund dont la meuf il a un morceau du
couscous et al
non non son aigle et tu sais que tu es
mort frère tu as roma l'a voulu faire de
la dinde mon frère et tu sais que la
dinde alliés c1 c'est parce on lire en
bas une dinde aux marrons frère voilà
fait des sandwichs à larissa avec thomas
walsh m est arrivé le marron dégueulasse
la meuf elle a perdu une dent masculin
je suis arrivé avec une bombe atomique
sur partie avec une meuf elle avait
trois ans
attention
au fait alors on présente pas en faire
là on ne prend pas de risque on ne prend
pas de risque je le dis franchement vous
il ça fait des années que vous prenez
pas de risques tu es comme ça
non mais je te dis toi avec roger
ne prend pas de risque ben nous on est
en ligne droite ligne droite c'est grave
quand même parce que au bout de la ligne
droite quel mur non mais je te le dis ça
va et crochets et ça va créer les jambes
à ce que les boîtes de nuits offertes
mais son mec pierre une boîte de nuit ah
oui c'est dur alors on espère qu'il y
aura les aides comme annoncé alors quoi
alors il pense pas du tout que ça
m'arrive rire lui pense qu'ils veulent
ils pensent qu aux aides à banon ça
apparaît au contraire je pense pas ses
morts donc y aura pas de soirée du jour
de l'an le hba1c content parce que je
voulais passer alors en train de
chauffer pernikoff il au niveau
sentimental maintien n'est pas nulle
part aucun risque en fait vous êtes
nulle part cela notamment
fonctionnellement
coûte aujourd'hui louis de bonald
bonne année comme ça 30 jours avant
d'annoncer votre tournée valoir